after two weeks of use and testing I
think that the iPhone 15 plus is the
best iPhone 15 upgrade this year and if
you want to buy a new iPhone and you're
considering which one to get this one
has seriously impressed me now last year
the iPhone 14 plus was quite a
disappointment for a number of reasons
and it was actually the worst selling
iPhone selling even worse than the minis
that it replaced so how in just a or do
I go from my least recommended iPhone to
my most recommended one well the first
thing has to do with price we're still
at the same
$900 but the 15 Pro Max now starts at
1,200 bucks so now it's a much bigger
spread in terms of price if you want
that larger screen now of course it
comes with 128 gigs of storage instead
of being forced to have 256 but 128 is
enough for most people now as far as the
design there have actually been quite a
bit of changes we're still using
aluminum like before but we have these
nice curved edges which just fit more
comfortably in your hand now as far as
weight this thing feels great because
for the size it is actually quite
lightweight lighter than the max phones
now with that I have to comment on the
new back glass the color is actually
embedded into the glass which is really
nice and for years Apple had shiny backs
on the regular iPhones and that means
you could see a ton of fingerprints
especially if you have a darker color
and it just looked ugly now we have this
mat that is very fingerprint resistant
even on the sides of the frames it just
looks much better than if you get a
Titanium Pro Max so I think that is
really nice and with that a lot of
people complain about the huge camera
bumps on iPhones and even though we had
some massive upgrades the bump size is
exactly the same so so it's not huge
it's not going to rock like crazy on
your desk now we also have USB type-c
which is a huge upgrade from lightning
the first time Apple switched over in so
many years and that just makes it so
much more convenient if you have other
devices now it does suck that is a USB
uh 2speed in here but realistically for
most people that are considering a
regular iPhone they are just going to be
using it for charging now one of the
most impressive things that shocked me
are the updates to the display of course
we have the dynamic Island now instead
of the notch that we've had for a year
so that's a huge noticeable difference
but we were not expecting Apple to use
the same high quality screen as in the
Pro phones to go from 1,000 in in
regular usage up to the same 2000 Peak
brightness which is so nice outside
beating out most Android phones and with
that HDR from 12200 up to 1,600 the same
quality as in the Pro phone so if you
have an older iPhone this difference is
huge now yes a big controversy is that
Apple's still using 60 HZ on these
phones in 2023 and that does suck I
agree but if you're somebody that
doesn't have promotion in an iPad or if
you haven't used a pro phone you're not
going to notice the difference so I
don't think that's a huge deal but not
having always on display does kind of
suck a bit and you got to ask yourself
if that is worth it to spend a lot more
money now one reason I really like this
phone is that Apple made a major upgrade
to the speakers the regular iPhone
lineup have always had worse speakers in
the pros but this year just with the
plus not the regular 15 they upgraded it
to match the 15 Pro Max which also had a
big improvement from the year before so
if you use your phone for Media or for
gaming with this large display and the
speakers the experience is awesome now
with that we have to talk about battery
life now last year the 14 plus was rated
better than the pro but when I did a
real world test that included real world
applications the difference was
practically the same but this year the
15 plus is amazingly good Mr who's the
boss did a crazy in-depth test and not
only you did Real World usage and in his
he got 13 hours and 19 minutes of
battery life compared to 11 hours and 41
minutes minutes for the 15 Pro Max that
is insane and this is the best battery
life that he has ever tested in a
smartphone and it's not even packed with
a 5,000 or 6,000 milliamp hour battery
so if you care about battery life this
is awesome and that is because of the
updates for example we have the a16 in
here so that's a little bit better and
with that we have the Qualcomm x70 modem
and if you don't know what that is
that's how you connect to a Cellular
Tower so that actually saves power
compared to last year and for many years
their cheaper iPhones actually had worse
modems than the Pro Models but this year
they are all the same and you get quite
a bit of better performance both indoors
and Outdoors than you do with the
previous model so as you guys could see
the plus is really going into Pro
territory and not only in that way now
as far as performance the a16 isn't that
far off from the a17
Pro which is a great thing you're not
missing out on a lot now of course
you're not going to get the rate tracing
or metal effects but unless you're going
to play the highest end games that are
not even out here yet you want to
maximize it most people aren't going to
care and still going to do an excellent
job now a huge talk this year was
thermal throttling we covered it a bunch
of times and all phones will slow down
but what shocked me is that the 15 plus
it actually performed a lot better than
the pro Max now while both of them did
Dim their screens when I really pushed a
hard load on them the 15 plus actually
went to full brightness in just 30
seconds compared to 2 minutes on the 15
Pro Max and why is that happening well
first off this chip does use less power
but with that because it's using
aluminum that does help dissipate heat
and aluminum is actually 16 times better
at transferring heat than titanium so
heat can spread out to the Edge and then
it be dissipated a lot better so if
you're worried about throttling that is
really nice and now I have to talk about
cameras because this thing is so
impressive it's the biggest jump that we
have seen in such a long time and
probably ever for a regular iPhone Apple
put in the same 48 megapix resolution
camera now the sensor is different but
it's actually newer than on the 15 Pro
Max and that allow them to get 2 x crops
for portraits and this is something that
I've been asking for for years now with
the regular iPhones you could only do
wide ones and then you can crop most
people would just get closer to their
subject and because of that you'd have
warping and here's an example that's a
little bit extreme but it shows what
happens and now you can put it into 2x
Mode still get insane quality and it's
just so much nicer now of course having
48 megapixels also gives you a ton more
detail but what it also really helps
with is for zooming um none of these
regular iPhones have telephoto lenses
you have the ultrawide and the main
camera and because of that it has to be
a digital crop but with 48 megapixels
you can now crop into 15 times instead
of five times when you're taking the
photo so that kind of negates the need
to have a 3X lens this really fixes the
zoom issue now with that we also got 24
megapixel images and that is amazing and
better than most Android phones that
gives you better quality and that also
works in both portrait modes and if
you're taking a live photo you also get
much better quality which you cannot do
that even with a 14 pro Max with that
Apple also gave you the ability to add
portrait mode after the fact because it
saves depth data so that is really cool
something you couldn't do before or with
the 14 pro series so as far as taking
photos this thing is so good as long as
you don't need that crazy Zoom it does
such an amazing job we also have Smart
HDR 5 better dynamic range and it is
just is super impressive now of course
we don't have apple raw or prores with
log but even for me somebody who a power
user and a photographer I rarely use
these features so 99% of regular people
will not care so last year the iPhone 14
and 14 plus they were minimal upgrades
and the 14 plus didn't really make sense
cuz you could spend just a little bit
more and get the pro Max but this year
the price difference is bigger but Apple
packed in way more upgrades into the 15
plus even compared to the regular 15
which makes it such a great value so if
you're on the line between which one to
buy out of the whole series maybe you
don't want to spend the extra money on a
15 Pro Max um or you want something um
that's just a little bit more simple you
don't need all the extras I think this
thing is an app absolute Great Value
this year if you've been waiting upgrade
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been Max and I'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one